Hello Freak bitches.
That's why my whole thing grow your own shit.
You know,
and not,
you don't have an end.
Like you said,
you don't have to grow everything yourself.
Right.
But if you do it collectively with your neighbors,
that's what I'm talking about.
It's like where you growing the apples and the,
and the carrots and Sally down the street is going some chart and rhubarb or
whatever the hell.
So now you can trade food and I can send my son to Yo spot until Yo give me some
carrots do from Joe's house and that's,
and vice versa.
You know,
you can send them over to my house and get some onions.
That's what I see,
man.
That's,
that's what it was.
So you have eliminated a couple of systems there and you've created community,
you created partnerships,
you create a business without,
without the money exchange and to,
and you've created safety,
you know,
so,
so that's,
and it's so damn simple to me and I guess it's going take me while it's so
simple that it's like,
but you guys know this,
right?
You know?
Yeah.
That's what's cool.
You're not talking about something that's like,
just been discovered,
some new technology that has recently been released to the public.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
And that's,
that's why as to me,
it's,
it's still somewhat mind boggling.
You know,
it's 100% mind boggling.
And what you said about community as giant because I think people live in this
weird place now where we barely even know our neighbors.
You know?
And the more populated the areas are,
the less likely you are to know your name.
And that's what I'm saying.
That's where the safety comes in.
Cause I know,
I know your son and I know he shouldn't be doing that and I know he should wait.
Yo Dude.
So I know,
you know,
so that's what,
that's where the safety comes in.
Right.
And that's where,
that's where the neighbor hood and that's where community comes in and that's
what caring for one another comes in.
And um,
it's,
to me,
we can do it,
it can happen.
I mean it's,
there's too many,
there's too many examples of this happening.
Now.
I've been talking about this on stage.
I think that once they develop artificial men,
like artificial human beings,
like blade runner style,
it's going to come.
There's going to be women that have sex robots in their house and we're going to
find out what women really like when,
when,
when you can actually buy a person that is an artificial person that was created
entirely in a lab and you could manufacture their personality and get it to
exactly where you want it to be and have them do anything you want them to do.
They're essentially robot sex slaves.
You're going to go over your grandma's house and she's going to have five,
seven foot tall Zulu warriors had just throw decoder all day.
That's going to be the reality.
That's what it's going to be.
You're going to go over your mom's house and everyone is going to look like
Arnold Schwarzenegger in his prime and they're all going to be walking around
with like Whitey tighties on a giant hogs at black Arnold.
Maybe.
Maybe she likes them all mixed up.
Maybe she likes Arnold.
Maybe it'll,
it'll be Arnold.
I mean they'll going to be able to recreate celebrities.
I mean,
Jennifer Lawrence is not just going to be on the cloud.
You're going to have her in your fucking dungeon.
You're going to have her locked up.
That's going to be real.
Look,
it's not that difficult to do.
If they can make a three d representation of her right now,
which is pretty accurate.
I mean the graphics that they can do right now in video games are fucking
credible and the CGI that can do is incredible.
And then you've seen that robot Japanese face where it's getting pretty creepy.
It's getting pretty creepy.
They're getting really close to human beings.
Well you went from uh,
having the Porsche Rs,
the 4.0
and then you went,
did you get a five,
nine,
$5?
I mean that's not goes down in history,
doesn't it as possibly the worst financial move ever.
I couldn't believe you did that.
First of all.
First of all,
get rid of like one of the greatest Porsche's ever.
We agreed we weren't going to talk about that.
It's just not fair.
You can't remind me of that.
That's like saying,
it's like me saying you had a,
you know,
you'll go from was Heidi Klum or something,
isn't it?
I think they remind me of that.
You got rid of one of the greatest cars ever that's worth so much money now.
That's the crazy thing,
right?
How much are they worth now?
I saw one for sale for 275,000 American.
Oh,
that with much more than that.
Yeah.
And the UK,
they're worth well over $350,000.
Wow.
Um,
so I did a right out of mine.
Hey,
look,
I,
I take a very philosophical view about this stuff.
I got to own a fully TRS.
I did things with it that not many people that own $40 is,
I've done,
I did big journeys.
I used it a lot.
There's a video of it stood up on youtube of it being driven in a completely
ludicrous manner.
That was my car.
Um,
it made me money.
that was a pretty nice thing to happen.
And at the time I didn't have any money.
You know,
I bet the House on that thing,
I used the last bit of cash,
I had to put the deposit down.
I didn't meet the financial criteria from Porsche,
so I had to beg,
steal and borrow to get them to lend me the money.
And then the payments were well over £1,000 a month and I wasn't earning much
money at the time,
so I couldn't really afford it.
I sort of kept going for,
I think we had it for a year and a bit,
and then I just had the set age.
It was just basic economics.
I couldn't afford the finance.
But then after that,
about six months after that,
I started earning a bit more money.
I had a couple of contracts that were quite good.
I had a bit of money.
And of course the medical condition means the moment you've got money,
you go straight out and buy a car,
don't you?
I didn't need a five,
nine,
nine.
It was absolute nonsense.
It costs me a fortune.
I lost a load of money.
I'm probably lost half the money I'd made on the port in it,
but I'd always wanted a five nine nine I,
I'm,
I view life as a series of boxes to tick.
Okay.
And it's quite binary.
It's just a series of ones and noughts and that's what I want to do.
And the 42 box had been ticked.
You know,
I,
I don't,
I don't really derive any pleasure from sitting and telling a room full of
people that I've got a 42 IRS.
I wouldn't,
I derive pleasure from driving it.
But once I had driven it quite a bit,
I can't kind of done it,
you know,
and I'm,
I'm lucky in that I can kind of use them to the,
to the full extent of their abilities.
That's a nice thing to know that you can do that.
You've driven a 42 rest to 100 of his ability as a nice thing to know.
And I'd done that.
And then I thought I quite like a five,
nine,
nine and the nine had the five nine,
nine for a year and realized that it was actually just too big.
And too fast for UK rose,
but I tick that box and then the next box to tick was probably a five 12 tr or
something like that,
or m three or there's just so much out there.
It's a bit like walking into a bookshop.
You need to know where to start.
D and I love that about the subjects I've got caught endlessly fascinating and
looking for the next thing that I want to enjoy it.
Yeah,
it is amazing.
And I think that when the f the football players have all demonstrated this
consistent pattern of brain trauma,
you know,
if they kissed each other all the time and they're trying to figure out how to
mitigate that,
but along the way,
the data becomes undeniable.
So now they're at that same spot where they're like,
the tobacco companies were okay,
cigarettes cause cancer,
but we still want it to be legal,
you know?
Okay,
okay.
Football causes brain damage,
but we still want to play it.
Do you guys still want to play football?
Who wants to make money?
Make money,
right?
You're worried about getting hit and had a couple of times,
okay,
we're going to do my best to not hit heads together,
but we're playing fucking football because when man,
right,
that's what happens and dudes will fucking march out there,
bro.
I'll fucking keep banging heads.
I'll still bang heads.
I'm going to fucking bang heads and get penalized for animals.
We're savages.
Especially like when you are just a complete stud athlete and you're involved in
this ultra competitive world of trying to dominate other stud athletes and spike
balls in their face and they're just fucking out there.
They're going to play.
I got gotta admit,
I just visualize this super stud athletes spiking the ball and I got a little
turned off so I can understand why they do it.
I can understand you.
Imagine that's you when you see what,
I don't watch as much football,
but I love highlight reels.
I love watching ESPN because they'll show like the best shit.
I don't have time to.
I don't understand the downs.
I really don't.
I don't even know the rules.
I don't know the rules of football.
Neither do I.
So we're on the same boat twos.
You're calling flags.
I'm like,
what is all this rest?
Why is everybody resting?
There should be just constant chaos.
I would want to see it like an MMA bow.
Just fucking five guys on this side.
Five guys on that side moved the ball,
go chaos,
craziness.
No breaks.
When you get it across,
you fucking march it back the other way and do it that way.
And no breaks,
no breaks,
no this whistle blowing.
And that white guy off the fucking field,
that little tiny white guy with the white outfit,
he's going to get killed.
So he's going to accidentally run over that fucker and he's going to die.
This 300 pound men on who knows God,
what kind of concoctions that are made in laboratories that have allowed them to
grow so big.
Okay.